Unicode characters
are just plain awesome.
As you just learned,
there are more than 110,000 characters.
That is insane.
In a moment, I want you to
explore some of them, because,
well they can certainly come in handy.
Why would you ever force the browser to
download an image when there's already
a Unicode character that you can get for
free?
To explore them yourself, I recommend
checking out this drop-down menu
which gives you the chance to look
through all of the different categories.
You can find things like emoticons.
Holy cow, look at all those cute
little emoticons that you get for
free, which you can use on any website.
It's worth pointing out that in order to
use Unicode characters, you need to make
sure that you set your character
set to utf-8 inside your meta tag.
See the instructor notes for
more details on this.
For this quiz, I want you to pretend
that you are making a music website.
Check out the link to the Unicode
character set that you can find in
the instructor notes.
Look through it and see if you can
find the symbol for the treble clef.
Once you've found it, try it out for
yourself and see if it works.
Once you're done,
paste the HTML code here to continue